well un officials are warning of a
breakdown of civil order in Gaza Over
The Limited delivery of desperately
needed humanitarian Aid as Israel's Army
continues to bombard the strip it's
announced changes to the rout that Aid
laes will have to take into the
Palestinian territory it says that
trucks carrying Aid will now undergo
Security checks at the Karam Abu Salem
Crossing until now Aid trucks were only
being screened at the Nana checkpoint
further south after being screened the
aid trucks travel back to Egypt and
finally enter Gaza through the Rafa
Crossing well Israel claims the new
inspection point will increase the
number of Aid trucks getting into Gaza
the UN says at least 200 trucks are
needed on a daily basis to meet basic
needs but only a fraction of that is
currently getting in the lack of Aid has
left Palestinians in a desperate state
of desperation many people haven't eaten
for days and a scrambling for the scarce
relief supplies that do reach the strip
let's return now to our correspondent in
occupied East Jerusalem Allan Fischer
Alan how much difference will this
additional security checkpoint make to
the amount of Aid that's getting into
the Gaza
Strip well the Israelis say it will make
a significant difference but there's a
few problems with it if they opened
caramel Salem they could check the
trucks and then they could drive
straight into Gaza but there's
opposition among some members of the
Israeli cabinet against allowing any aid
from isra is directly into Gaza so
they're being checked at this checkpoint
this border crossing and then being sent
all the way around to Rafa where they
will enter where they will join the line
of trucks that are waiting to get into
Rafa now on Sunday there were 100 trucks
got into Gaza the United Nations say at
the moment they need a bare minimum of
200 trucks before the war they were
getting around 400 500 600 trucks a day
bringing in food medical supplies fuel
things that made life in Gaza bearable
so the fact that all these trucks are
now queued at Rafa means that there's a
longer time to get them in here's
another added difficulty the Red Cross
say that there is a problem just
navigating the roads because they're in
such terrible condition after the
incessant Israeli bombardment and also
they're not entirely sure if they send
the trucks in that they won't come under
Fire that there won't be an outbreak of
violence an outbreak of War where these
trucks are heading so that adds to the
problem so clearing the trucks at one
security checkpoint is something but
it's not everything they need to get
more trucks into Gaza and at the moment
the Israelis are only letting that
happen through Rafa and that is creating
a choke choke point meaning that the aid
that is needed isn't getting to the
people who need it okay Alan Fisher
reporting there from occupied East
Jerusalem Alan thank you